okay today I'm going to talk to you
about rate of reaction experiments all
this means is experiments to determine
how quickly a reaction occurs how
quickly does a reaction occur so it's
different experiments that we can set up
in order to find this out in order to
determine the rate of reactions so the
first one we need to know about is a
precipitation reaction so what a
precipitation reaction is is when we
have two solutions that mix together and
a solid is formed now this is how it
works what we can do is we can get a bit
of paper or a bit of white card and on
there we could put a cross just draw a
cross on it because what happens next is
we have a conical flask this is where
our reactions going to take place that
we put on top of the cross we also we're
going to use a stop clock in all of
these different experiments we need a
stop clock because remember we're
finding out the rate of reaction how
quickly it occurs so always in these
we're going to need a stop clock so what
we do next is we mix these solutions
together our two solutions together and
we start the stop clock now over time
what will start to happen is a
precipitate will start to form and
slowly but surely will eventually get to
a point where we can no longer see the
cross the second or you could no longer
see this across you stop the stop clock
and that gives you your value so let's
say that is 50 seconds so this isn't a
particularly accurate rate of reaction
experiment because it's very subjective
what that means is one person might say
I can't see the cross anymore a few
seconds before someone else would so
it's down to people's opinions a little
bit making it subjective now with all of
these rate of reaction experiments if
you have to outline them in an exam
please remember to mention that you need
to repeat it three times and then find
the mean that's really really important
always in science when we repeat our
experiments in order
to find the mean so the next rate of
reaction experiment we need to know is a
change in mass experiment so what we've
got this time is we've got a conical
flask again that's where our reaction is
going to take place and on there we have
we have a conical flask so here's sorry
electronic balance is underneath so
let's say my starting value of my
electronic balance balance right at the
beginning just the second we mix the
reactants together is 115 grams so again
we need a stop clock as well so here's
my stop clock now these ones only work
when we're producing a gas because what
happens is as the reactants react
together gas is released and leaves via
the top of the conical flask as this
happens this this mass will go down so
let's say we have this let's say what we
do is we mix the wrecks together at the
very very start a second we mix it
together we take a reading of the mass
and we start stop clock so over time
this value will go down as gas is being
released so let's say we'll time it for
60 seconds that's a sensible amount of
times time for one minute so let's say
the end of these 60 seconds it's gone
from being 115 grams to 103 grams so how
do we find a rate of reaction from this
well what we need to do is we need to
take our starting mass and take away our
ending mass which gives me my change in
mass so how much gas has been released
during the experiment in grams now this
isn't a rate of reaction yet because
this is how much how the mass of gas
released in 60 seconds but I want to
show how much gas has been released
every second so in order to do that I
say 12 grams divided by 60 which equals
just use a calculator for this bit 12
divided by 60 which
0.2 now a units for this is grams per
second so every single second I'm losing
0.2 grams of of my substance of product
okay
so that is how to use this to find the
change in mass again remember always
when we're talking about experiments to
say repeat three times and find the mean
now the final one we need to know about
why all we need to know about is using
the volume of gas produced so again we
have a conical flask so this is where my
reaction is going to take place in the
conical flask there is a bung in the top
now this bung just make sure any gas
doesn't get released into the into the
air around it into the atmosphere
instead what we have is a delivery tube
which goes into a syringe okay so this
syringe can actually be used to measure
the volume of gas produced so let's say
again as always in all of these
experiments I need a stop clock so
here's my stop clock just here lovely
stuff so what I do is I put my reactants
together and the second they're added
together
I start my stop clock so what will
happen is as the gas is produced it will
travel up here into the syringe and it
actually pushes back the plunger on the
syringe so what will happen over time is
I'll be able to accurately read the
volume of gas produced so again we need
to think of a sensible amount of time to
time it for 60 seconds would be sensible
so one minute and I'll then see read on
here to see how much gas was produced in
60 seconds so let's say 30 centimeters
cubed of gas was produced in 60 seconds
how do I turn this into a rate of
reaction so if 30 centimeters of cubed
was produced in 60 seconds
what I need to do to find how much was
produced in one second would be 30
divided by 62 30 divided by 60 which
equals 0.5 now my units are going to be
different this time
because instead of looking at grams I've
looked at centimeters cubed so my units
this time are going to be centimeters
cubed per second so just like with the
other ones the really key bit of
information at the end whenever you're
doing an experiment please remember to
repeat it three times and then find the
mean in order to get reliable results
thank you